the more people you bring into a city
and they're bringing them in in Mass
hundreds of thousands per month you will
see more wear and tear and you're going
to pay for that so when everyone was
complaining that we had pothole problems
that weren't being fixed to the point
where fast food companies started doing
it themselves as
advertising this is caused by higher
population density that's that's that's
it and if you're okay with paying the
bills and dealing with these stresses of
population density by all means but this
means there's going to be more crime
food's going to be more expensive
parking will be non-existent it's
already very crowded in New York it's
crazy now just keep adding more people
and see how that goes I mean also we
know for a fact that they're not willing
to pay any of the costs associated with
increased migration they're just okay
with people who live in Border towns or
in states that are being flooded to have
to pay those cost as soon as they get
imported into their neighborhoods they
freak out and shoe all of them away they
actually call the National Guard and we
saw that in Martha's Vineyard yeah you
see Eric Adams is suing the bus
companies now instead of going after the
government I don't know if you saw that
he's suing the actual coachs about right